on behalf of the entire Stanford
community thank you so much for taking
the time to talk with us today I'm
delighted to get the chance to have this
conversation
I'd like to structure the interview
around two forms of leadership your
approach to leading the Global Alliance
and then secondly renault-nissan
leadership in both electric vehicles and
autonomous driving two things I'll
promise all my questions won't be as
long as his first one and please excuse
my my French accent but if we could go
back to 1999
you were the the deputy CEO over know
which at the time was I think 44% owned
by the French government as the Dean
said Nissan was hemorrhaging money
I believe you found later only 4 or 43
models that sold were profitable it had
lost domestic market share for 27 years
in a row at 27 to 21 billion dollars of
debt Daimler Chrysler the world's
biggest car maker at the time you know
did their diligence backed out of an
acquisition that they said they would
have been better off putting 5 billion
dollars in the shipping container and
putting in the ocean that investing in
Nissan Louis share the CEO of Renault
told you he was willing to bet the
company's future on the alliance with
Nissan but only on the condition that
that you would agree to lead the
recovery and I guess at a personal level
your wife and four children had just
moved back to Paris from the US and you
didn't speak Japanese how did you think
about that that offer to go go to Nissan
well look I think from time to time you
have opportunities coming you are not
expecting them you just have to make a
decision you take them or not
independently of how much chance of
success you have it's I would say
irrelevant even if I consider I had ten
percent of chance of being successful I
would have taken it because you know we
all want to make something which outlast
us in a certain way something where
you're bringing a strong contribution
which is measurable which is visible
where you can really you know say there
was a before and after and this was this
huge opportunity obviously it was a
complete mess in my own life
professional life personal life because
we were you know coming back from the
United States settling in in Paris you
know buying a house etcetera kids were
moving to the French to the French
system and tell them we're going to go
to Japan and nobody spoke Japanese
nobody knew anything about Japan but you
need to make a choice I saw from the
beginning that she was a huge
opportunity obviously extremely
dangerous because you had no certainty
of any kind that you would you would
prevail but I had no hesitation I mean
I'm from the beginning I said well
that's it that was I was expecting
something like this to happen and I took
it immediately can you can you tell us a
little bit about what your first day at
Nissan was like what are you doing
that's it why are you going to be
disappointed because you know when you
arrive first day I mean first day you
arrive in Japan you don't speak Japanese
you know everybody who has been educated
into the Western system the knowledge
about Asia is pretty poor pretty you
know simple simplistic I didn't speak
Japanese I know too much about Japan I
obviously had Japan in the back of my
mind because of the importance of Japan
in the car industry and the first day I
arrived I also was looking for my
translator because without my translator
I could not do anything I just forget to
know her
you make a phone call you know what the
list of the name of the people that you
need to meet first people in the
executive committee the corporate
officers where of the main location the
plants location of Nissan what are the
main technical centers of Nissan flowers
during my first day trying to establish
just the communication system and the
list of the places where I need to go
and the people any to meet so so I can
think of a number of global consulting
firms that that would have said their
core competency is to come in and help
you solve problems like this you
specifically didn't want outside
consultants why not no this is this I
mean when you want to turn around a
company you want to make sure that the
solution is coming from inside I mean
anything that looks like it's an it's an
outside based solution this is something
which has been fabricated by people
coming out of the body of the company
maybe it's much smarter maybe it's much
more adequate but at the end of the day
everything is about execution and when
it comes to execution you want people
buying in and people will never buy in
as much as it is our plan it's our own
plan so from the beginning I know I've
been contacted by so many consultant
firms who wanted to give a hand some of
them propose their services free I mean
even if it looks a little bit strange I
said no because I wanted really the plan
to be nice on plan made by Nissan I mean
I didn't even want the Renault people to
be involved into the Turner the revival
plan of Nissan I wanted to be done by
the Nissan people mainly by Japanese
people in Japan but also the American
Nissan people in the United States
European people etc so the solution
comes from inside and people would say
this is our plan and we're going to
execute it maybe the plan would have
been better with the consultant maybe
it's not sure but I can tell you when it
comes to execution you know it could not
have been better because I had a 100%
buy-in when the plan was decided and
people knew that it was their own ideas
obviously remodelled
that we're going to be implemented I had
to complete a complication so so can you
tell us a little bit about what you did
differently or how you how you helped
Renault help itself or how many sunglass
off let me tell you that mean the the no
matter what is the company which is in
trouble my experience shows me that you
don't need to look for the solution
outside its inside it is it is always
inside you just need to look for it
obviously solution is not unique it's a
build up of specific opportunities that
you're going to transform into a plan
with priorities with a timeframe with
specific goals and with achievements so
I was just looking for it I knew it was
inside I was looking for it and
obviously the best way to look for it is
interview as many people as possible
particularly people in critical process
area that's why you need to know a
little bit the industry to know where
you're looking where you're looking for
let me give you an example 50% of the
P&L of car company is purchasing you
know I mean Nissan has in 110 billion
dollars sales a year from the 110
billion dollar sales you have about
fifty five billion dollars or buying we
buy parts we buy commodities we buy
services with by transportation with
everything so if you don't buy well you
can do miracles on anywhere you want
you're not going to people you need to
make sure that your purchasing process
is in line so number one number one
priority number two number two priority
making sure for example that you know
exactly what are the segments on the
market where you have legitimately so
you can release your name you can
establish the brand into this particular
segment so you need to establish what
are the priority and then you say okay
why am I even though I have a keiretsu
why my purchasing cost is much higher
than for example the rental purchasing
cost which was a smaller company Why Why
Honda and Toyota is making so much money
where Nissan which is having the same
workforce with the same engineer coming
from the same University part of the
same culture did not get results so
little by little you go through a very
common-sense approach where you say
these are the most important processes
let me go and see the pea
who are in charge of the process or
around this process interview them
what's wrong what do you think is wrong
how can you fix it
okay so obviously solutions are going to
come like this but by listening to
hundreds of people into this process I
can tell you that mean the solution
comes very clearly now
people usually avoid the dramatic
solution for example we had over
capacity nobody want to talk about
shutting down plans in Japan why because
it is something which is sacred no you
know shutting down the plant in Japan is
something that nobody does nobody do
that mean it's something has to be
forced at the certain point in time
dismantling the keiretsu nobody's going
to tell you carrier is not working we're
going to tell you yeah we're buying at a
higher price and then you go see the
people in the care issue and they tell
you why they have to sell Nissan at the
higher price than Honda and Toyota
so interviewing asking question we're in
a very simple way and then it's going to
look it's going to look very clear
people contribute to it they may not
like the final shape of the of the plan
but if you commit to results everybody
joined so I mean it may look like common
sense in retrospect but I think every
expert you have talked to at the time
would have said hey you know there's a
Japanese way of doing business and and
this is how things are done in every
class you would take and how to do
business in a global environment would
say you respect local cultures and and
but like what gave you the confidence I
am just a task whoa I am NOT going to
challenge you know what you're learning
at the University particularly telling
you that you know but but but when you
go and you are a foreigner going to
Japan you're going to Japan for one
reason and that's it it's turning around
the company period that's what people
expecting from you how much work what do
you do if if you have problems if you
have remorse impact either nobody cares
fix it that's it that's a message fix it
you accept the job you have to fix it we
had two main problems one the main
problem of Nissan is that we had 20
billion dollars of debt in 1999 and no
Japanese bank
and you know how flexible Japanese Bank
can be for a Japanese company no
Japanese bank wanted to land any money
to Nissan so we were facing a cash
crunch okay this is immediate death okay
so we need to establish the trust on it
and cut the depth second you need to
come back to profit for ten years
Nissan had one percent average operating
profit while Honda and Toyota we're
around seven to ten percent we had about
one percent return on invested capital
where our main competitors were at more
10% there was something wrong you need
to establish your establish G's put it
put it right so I knew from the
beginning that what I suspected from me
is fix it fix it so when you know you
need to fix it you can say okay I'm
going to make as many changes as
necessary to fix the problem nothing
more nothing more so changing the habits
if there is no obvious result you
shouldn't do but when you know that
fixing the company is going to force you
to change some habits wagon you need to
say it you need to explain why you're
doing it and particularly you need to
commit to the results because people
don't like change as long as there is no
commitment to specific results behind
the change now if you commit to specific
results they may give you the benefit of
the doubt and that's exactly what
happened in the case of Nissan as you
know I spent three months building the
plan listening to people and everybody
told me you cannot shut down a plant in
Japan you cannot dismantle the keiretsu
in in Japan you cannot challenge the
seniority system in Japan you cannot put
younger people in top jobs in Japan
diversity etc etc I mean the list of you
cannot do this and that was huge so I
had two choices first choice I listened
to all of this then the consequence is I
take back the family I take back my bag
I go back to France because there was
nothing I could do the second one is I
need to fix it then I need to say okay I
cannot do everything but let's do the
changes that are going to deliver
results so I have dismantled the
carriers who are in sanh not because I
consider the carriers who was a wrong
solution but I said the karriesue didn't
work for Riza
it's working for Toyota it's work
in for Honda good for them it didn't
work for us that's why we're changing it
I challenge the seniority system by
saying it's not have nothing about
people who are 50 or 60 or 70 years old
but I don't want a segregation against
younger Japanese people who had a lot of
talent and who cannot access the jobs of
responsibility even though they deserve
so I turned it around I see that we need
to stop the segregation against young
people into the system and always with
the specific objective care that in
dismantling the cross-shareholding with
many companies I've done everything but
every single time explain why and
particularly the most important thing I
committed to resign if one year after we
started the plan the company would not
be in the black and I said we're going
to divide the depth of 20 billion
dollars by by 2 within the within 3
years term and that the company growth
would resume after having 10 years of of
decline and I said if any one of this
objective is not met I'm out and
obviously with me all the members of the
executive committee so this commitment
which was very strong because this was
not a commitment in a boardroom this was
a commitment on TV in front of the
public so everybody knew that you're
gonna have to deliver or get up give
give me and give us the benefit of the
doubt the rest of the story you know it
so I mean Nissan had gone through many
strategic plans previously and I think
you famously said strategy is 5 percent
of the answer and execution is 95
percent so so what does that mean and
how did you actually what did you do
differently but you know the five
percent yeah I said yeah five percent of
the challenge is a strategy 95 percent
of the execution this I said it as CEO
of Nissan I said it also a CEO Freneau
and I said it as deputy CEO of Renault
when I said the first time it was mainly
in France and I was to my to to the top
management of Renault in France because
there was a tendency in the company to
spend too much time on strategy and
leave the execution for other people and
this is where I said yeah
strategy is fine it's very important but
it's only five percent
if you don't go to execution after this
the delivery and the performance of the
company is going to be very weak I
really I really believe it now it
doesn't mean Serge is not important but
when you establish north and you know
exactly where north is for the company
you've done something very important
because you're giving the direction but
if you don't start moving north if you
don't start mapping and establishing
milestone you know you're never going to
be getting there you're never going to
be getting there you know in the car
industry if you noticed when you see the
evolution of our industry for the last
thirty years there have been a
tremendous change a lot of companies
which were number one number two number
three worldwide downgraded and weakened
and a lot of newcomers coming up if when
you take a look to the new leaders of
the industry all of them have one thing
in college a panniers you have Germans
you have Koreans you have Franco
Japanese you have everything there is
one thing in common is the discipline of
execution and the importance of
processes like in in our industry at the
end of the day yes strategy is important
but at the end of the day the most
disciplined organization the
organization which gives a lot of
importance to processes and up
prevailing who's number one in our
industry today Toyota who's number two
Volkswagen who's number three depending
if you consider volume or revenues let's
say it's between General Motors and
ourself Renault Nissan who number five
Hyundai Hyundai Kia what it change
compared to 20 years ago when you take a
look to the classification of this
industry twenty years ago it's a
complete it's a complete change what's
in common for it is for out of these
five top companies big discipline in
execution a lot of importance given to
processes it's not sufficient but this
is where the difference is being made
one of the stories I liked for initial
arrival in Japan was you decided the
executives we've been too far removed
from
from the product from the car and so you
moved your executive meetings to the
test track can you talk about that a
little bit oh that's that I mean our
industry is an industry around the
product and everything start from there
and ends up here is I don't think you
can consider anybody to be at the top of
our industry without a strong
contribution in terms of product
whatever it is technology or quality or
reliability or perceived quality or
pricing everything is around the product
so understanding the product is
absolutely fundamental and asking top
management in our industry no matter
what is their function that can be chief
financial officer they can be specialist
of HR they don't have to be engineers
and especially of the product but the
fact that they put themselves in the
shoes of the consumer listen to the
advantages the weaknesses the
opportunities comparing our product to
the one of the of competitors is
absolutely essential
so maybe back to what you talked about
for discipline in Michigan sorry
Michelin your second job out of training
was as the Dean said manager of a
factory that made huge tires for heavy
equipment I checked our most recent
employment report and there were no
factory managers leaving Stanford
Business School are there things that
you learn there that that affect your
decision-making process as the CEO of
two global manufacturing companies yeah
I mean I I considered that the what we
call manufacturing today or the
monozukuri I use a Japanese term of
monozukuri monozukuri is everything
which covers a product planning
engineering manufacturing supply chain
this is all the area of the company
where the product is born okay
versus marketing distributing selling
financing etc this area of the company
particularly for products which are not
commodity products which are changing
all the time absolutely essential and
having starting your carrier in my
opinion starting your carrier in this
area where you are at the crossroad of
many
things turning around the products
absolutely essential I wanted to be in
manufacturing because in manufacturing
first you deal with people
second you deal with the product third
we deal with supplier then we live is
quality so everything in one place and
manufacturing the plant is on the first
place where the product is born before
the manufacturing the product is just
the fiction it's on a computer it's on a
design but the first place where the
product exists is in manufacturing so I
wanted to start in manufacturing and
frankly I don't I don't regret it and I
can tell you some of our top executives
both in renault-nissan not all of them
but some of the top executive often come
from a background of what we call
monozukuri and a lot of them from
manufacturing and so going on perhaps a
decade of running simultaneously to two
global companies how do you get the
stamina to keep going and to stay fit
you know personally and and mentally and
physically well you know somebody said
with a little discipline you do little
things with a lot of discipline you do a
lot of things and we total discipline
there is nothing which you cannot do it
requires a lot of discipline I mean
obviously because you're going to move
from one world to the other from one
culture to the other from two completely
different company yeah jet LAG's
organization people are expecting you
when you come down from a plane after 14
hours flight to be fresh and ready for
them that they are not expecting the CEO
to come and say oh my god is jet lag he
cannot answer a question they want you
to be on the go all the time so this
requires a lot of discipline you have to
organize yourself if you know you're
going to do this job and you accept the
job you have to organize yourself in
order to do it it's tough but there is a
solution there is there is a solution
for it but it requires a lot of choices
personal choices there are a lot of
things you cannot do you know there are
a lot of things you can do but you're
going to do them within a certain order
but particularly with a lot with a lot
of discipline can you give us some
examples of how you how you've done that
personally yeah I can I can give you I
can give you my my program the most
thing is
my program for this week and next week
for example I mean just not to go
yesterday I was into the pre
inauguration of a new plant that Nissan
is building in Brazil so a lot of you
can say yeah lucky you you were in Rio
Janeiro there's no complaint but I was
in Rio Janeiro in in fact in the state
of Rio Janeiro in Rezende I reviewed the
new plant of Nissan was going to be
inaugurated in April so I was spent the
day in resin they took the plane flew I
am here today later I'm going to our
research center that we have opened in
Silicon Valley in order to make sure
that we understand what the startup are
doing particularly around autonomous
driving we're gonna probably talk about
it so Wednesday night tomorrow night I'm
going to our headquarter in the United
States which is based in Nashville we're
going to have a review with all the
North American team about about the
performance I'm going to visit Canton
Mississippi Friday which is one of our
large plant on on Friday then I'm flying
for Japan next week I will be Monday in
Tokyo I will be in Tokyo from Monday to
Friday executive committee board meeting
corporate officer meeting investment
committee etc you go through all the all
the elements and then I'm flying for
Paris so I mean I have my schedule for
2014
booked already that's all we know
okay I mean yeah you have to accept that
I mean I know exactly where I'm going to
be hopefully in December 2014 all the
board meeting of both company already
set executive committee the visit to the
plant everything has to be organized if
not there is no way you can do
everything you have you have to from
time to time we have accidents from
Dante accidents but fortunately I'm
surrounded by professional people who
can adapt to the situation and make the
necessary changes you know how do you do
it it's possible but it requires a lot
of discipline do you think there aren't
any fundamentals about leadership that
transcend a specific company or industry
I mean you have a personal leadership
philosophy
yeah but you know leadership also
depends on the time I don't think if
you're a good leader today you're going
to be a great leader can years down the
road or twenty years down the road and I
don't think that the great leader of
today would have been a great leader
twenty years ago I think it's a DAT to
the time if I take today and the
foreseeable future there are some
attributes in my opinion which are
absolutely necessary for leadership
position particularly for companies but
not only for company and the number one
the number one attribute I think is what
I call empathic the capacity to connect
with people that's extremely important
why I'm telling you this because you
know I when I look at the Alliance we
have about four hundred and fifty
thousand people working in the lines our
first group of people are Russian this
is the largest number of employees we
have are Russians the second largest
group of employees we have is Chinese
the third largest group we have is
Japanese and the fourth is French and
then you continue like this and you have
American you have British etc and when
you have 450,000 people with very large
group of people spread all over the
world the capacity to connect the
capacity to understand the capacity to
get out from your own reality and try to
see what's on the mind of your own
people who are fighting on different
fronts it is for me absolutely essential
and it's going to continue to be
essential for many years to come
this is a basic attribute frankly if I
find somebody in my team and he has no
impetus kappa he doesn't have the
capacity to connect I think's going to
be very hard for him to be in leadership
position now being in having this
impetus capacity Connect is not
sufficient I'm saying it's a basic and
absolutely necessary condition for
leadership obviously you have other
attribute but you're asking me some of
them I'm telling you I consider empathy
is is probably the most importantly I
think you are said would you say
decisiveness is number two is that you
what was the second one I decide
since you talked about like the flipside
of empathy and decisiveness and uh yeah
decisiveness is number two but
decisiveness doesn't mean quick decision
decisiveness mean adequate decision at
the right time and the right time may
not be the quick time you know
particularly that is something I learned
in Asia because obviously when you take
a CEO job and a company you learn a lot
you learn a lot one of the thing I
learned particularly in Japan that from
time to time making quick decision is
going to hurt the execution of the
decision because I think what you want
when you make a decision what you want
you want to transform reality you don't
want to make a decision for the sake of
making a decision you make a decision
because you want something to change so
your goal is the thing changed that's
your goal so now the question is when
should you make the decision in order to
make sure that this thing has changed in
the fastest period of time so from time
to time you have to wait to make the
decision because you're preparing people
to execute from time to time you need to
make the decision very early from time
to time a little bit late but when I say
this is eveness mean capacity to take
the decision at the appropriate time
because at the end of the day what you
need is reality changes that's that's
your goal so I know we promised we
talked about electric cars as well and
and I mean that your Alliance has made
has made you know tremendous investment
you know billions of euros in zero
emission vehicles at the New York Auto
Show in 2011 you know I think you said a
fairly public goal that you would double
sales of the leaf in 2012 didn't really
play out that way what do you think
happened and and what needs to change to
move the leaf and other electric cars
from from niche players into mass market
leaders yeah what you know I I consider
that the future of our industry is based
mainly from still with oil but second
with electricity
when I say electricity is purely
electric car or electrified electrified
power train there's no doubt about it
so you see multiplication of the hybrids
mild hybrids through hybrids flex-fuel
electric cars
we're moving into this direction one of
the reasons for which electric car now
I'm talking about pure electric car is
not going as fast as I would like it to
go is the lack of infrastructure we're
saying every single time a city a state
or a country put the investment in terms
of infrastructure the sales of electric
car move up we are selling today in the
United States three thousand leaf a
month thirty six thousand cars you're
going to say yeah but you know thirty
six thousand cars in the United States
out of we sell more than 1 million cars
in the United States we're going to say
its peanuts yeah but it's a huge change
because people buying the leaf today we
have the highest level of satisfaction
of any other car that they die by and
most of them don't want to change I mean
that by electric car a used electric car
they establish their routine with the
charging system etc they just love the
cars I want to continue with it and its
increasing the last three months the
most sold car in Norway was electric car
it was relief so the Chinese have given
to ourselves themselves objectives in
terms of electric cars but they didn't
pipe the bullet yet because there is no
Chinese technology for electric cars are
waiting for Chinese car makers to really
master the technology of wrecked car in
order to hit it
Japan is is is putting a lot of
incentive the charging system in Japan
is really developing I have zero doubt
on the fact electric car is a big part
of the future where we don't control and
we are little bit frustrated in the
speed at which the charging
infrastructure is is spreading and I can
tell you I was you know I think two
years two years ago my daughter who was
on the campus was driving a leaf and a
certain moment in time she said okay I
need to charge the car I say well it's
interesting let's go to the charging
station and at that moment there were
only two charging station on the campus
but both were occupied so I said so what
what you do now say well I can't drive
the car I need to wait for the these two
cars to be removed
so we've seen that mean the charging
system is a real concern before we see a
take off of of the sales but it's coming
it's coming because a lot of cities a
lot of states are investing not only in
the United States but France Japan China
we are signing agreement with cities
with different cities now it's coming I
have zero doubt on it it's much slower
than we thought but it's not slow
because the technology is not ready it's
low mainly because the infrastructure is
not moving fast enough you were here
visiting the engineering school and may
have to talk about autonomous vehicles
can you just share your thoughts about
why you're so excited about about
autonomous vehicles what autonomous
vehicle because in fact we are we are
moving from a period of time where the
car is a slave you know do you brake you
start to a partner now it's giving you
information adapting to what you want
and we have the pieces of technology to
do it what does it mean the car is your
is your is your partner for example
today we have the devices in which you
get to the car the car can measure your
temperature it can define what's your
mood you can switch the music you
adapted to you'd and function of you're
excited you're angry you're frustrated
you're happy it can lower the
temperature into the car or or heighten
it it can detect an accident one or two
miles in front of you and change the
lane or slow the temperature or reroute
or reroute you there are a lot of things
that where the car can become your
partner that mean you don't have to
decide it will decide for you as long as
you have pre-program it for it
why I think autonomous driving is going
to be big thing for the for the car
industry a lot of objective reason the
first one is we want zero accident any
car company would like zero accident the
only way you move to zero accident is
autonomous driving because 95% of
accidents happening on the street are
human mistake if you eliminate human
mistake you get a minute ASEA that's
number two a baby born today has 50% of
probability to live 100 years a lot of
people lose their driving license at 75
70 80 years old so if you can imagine
that a big part of the world population
moving toward 100 years old and you
start losing your driving licence at 70
75 years old you have a problem because
the last one years are going to be
little bit difficult without autonomous
transportation the only way going to
solve it with autonomous driving because
autonomous driving you can be
handicapped you can have a lot of
physical problem impairment and you can
still get into the car input the address
and the car will will will drive it
there so for me it's a need in terms of
safety it's a need in terms of expansion
of autonomous of autonomous
transportation it's good for us because
it's an expansion of our market but also
is going to be an essential element for
for senior for senior people and the
pieces of technology are ready we have
the different technologies that allow us
our estimate is today we have already
announced officially that autonomous
driving will take place as mass-marketed
cars by 2020 we have already
authorization in Japan and I know that
we have there are some authorization in
the United States to allow autonomous
driving testing on the road so my last
question before I open the open up to
the floor for Q&A the question that the
Dean asks all of us when we apply to
Stanford Business School is what matters
most to you and why how would you answer
that today what matters most well I
think what what matters most is making a
difference that what matters most today
make any difference I mean it can be
professionally but it can be socially it
can be the father it can be as professor
as academician you want to make a
difference that's what matters most you
you want to say well you know I'm
dedicating part of my life to do this I
want to have the impression that I made
a difference no matter how you measure
this difference
but the way you measure the difference
must be important for you okay I think
that's what matters all the time as long
as you think you can make a difference
while you have the motivation to push
you whatever you're pursuing and I'm not
talking only on the field of
professional life I'm talking also on
the field of the personal life or on
contributing to Angie or contributing to
other to other things in love I think
this is for me the most important thing
that you can see that what you're doing
is something where you know that if you
were not there things would have been
different and hopefully by you being
there you know part of a team or part of
a company is going to get is going to
get better but obviously when you turn
around the situation you have you have a
huge satisfaction because you say oh you
know I was here I was part of the team
who made this transformation okay so
it's obvious but in some other case is a
little bit more difficult to see thank
you so much so move to questions from
the audience the session is being
recorded so it's important have a
microphone before we ask a question so
please raise your hand and one of the
ushers will bring the microphones around
thank you very much for the interview so
I have a question about the
terminologically and it means creating
something in Japanese and you said in
the Sun more logically covers everything
every step in value chain from R&D to
marketing and my sense is in Japan
sometimes the Japanese company is too
much focused on more logically and they
focus on R&D and in technology trying to
have some innovation from technological
side and failed to attract their
customers in the market so my feeling is
they should shift on the mind step
automatically and try to focus more on
the market side so what do you see this
trend and how do you think the more
logically are hinders the Japanese
companies to try to articulate the
customers nice yeah well I know I think
it's a it's a great observation to say
Japanese company have a tendency to try
to create innovation out of technology
too much versus other company who are
going to go and try to assess or NEADS
or aspiration from from from consumers
that's why I believe that alliances
between companies of different cultures
are so powerful because each one bring
with his own culture his own strength
and in our case if you can marry the
strengths of the monozukuri in Japan to
the creativity which comes with the
French approach and as you know we have
a partnership with Daimler with which we
develop also a lot of Technology so when
you bring companies as long as the
company remain autonomous obviously
because if you merge all of this then
automatically you're going to blend
everything into one culture and you're
going to lose some of the benefits from
diversity as long as you can make
company with different culture working
together you're going to get the best
out of every single single culture but I
agree with you and that if if you have
if you are monocultural the risk of you
being too much benefiting from your own
strengths and ignoring your own
weaknesses are very big that's why
having Japanese company working with the
German company working
the French company is such a delight
because we come to solutions that you
could have never imagined by ourselves
no matter where we're coming from
so I totally agree with you that's why I
think Japanese company coupled with
other company as long as they know how
to make these things happen can be
extremely extremely efficient going back
there sorry I'm Melissa from MX program
thanks for coming my question is about
common sense you talked about when you
arrived in Japan and you use your common
sense to make some decisions to change
the to make some decisions about the
process things like that but my
observation is that a lot of leaders
they don't have the common sense you are
talking you talked about I want to know
how did you how to get the common sense
did you have it on the first day when
you were working or was there a process
Thanks yeah what you know uh yeah how do
you get going Sam this is an interesting
question
how do you get common sense well you
know common sense common sense means but
we are human being we have aspiration
and from time to time we get off track
no matter who we are at what position we
get off track and common sense is what
bring you back on track when I went to
when I went to Nissan common sense
indicated that I was coming to Nissan
and accepted in Japan for one reason is
fixing Nissan period I was not there to
make a show I was not there to lecture
Japan about what needs to be done even
though a lot of people you know we're
calling for these kind of things so
every time I were never deviated from my
mission because I had this whatever we
call it common sense bringing back by
saying you know you're here you're in
this job because people want you to fix
the company period
okay that's common sense common sense
means go back to the basics go back to
the fundamental needs and make sure you
understand you know what's your
contribution what's the expectation
what's the expectation from you I agree
with you from time to time some people
lack common sense very unlikely they're
going to get to leadership position in
my opinion particularly in the business
world very unlikely some of them escaped
but the most frequent I know the most
frequent thing is people lose common
sense after they come to leadership
position and this is a real risk that's
why I think having strong teams and
strong boards which are focused on these
are the essential things we need to do
are absolutely important so if you lose
your common sense somebody's going to
remind you you know that's why you are
here and that's what we're expecting
what you're expecting from you but I
agree with you it happens that you can
lose your common concepts in the back
row over there hi I'm Alex a second year
MBA student and I'm curious to get your
view on developing countries boost for
for a company your company perspective
as well as us student how can we capture
the growth in emerging countries you
know there are a lot of literature today
on emerging market three years ago as
you know four years ago it was sky was
the limit today a lot of people said
this is the end of it this was just the
bus etc emerging market are here to grow
and they are here to grow for the long
term they are not all growing they're
not going to grow all on the same rate
Brazil is not going to grow at the same
rate than China is I'm going to go a
same rate than India Russia or Myanmar
or Vietnam or Cambodia or Mexico
everyone has a different reality but
there are some things which are
absolutely fundamental is that all of
them are going to grow and depending on
the field that you are considering you
have you can estimate what kind of
growth is going to happen you don't know
what's the timing of the growth how much
time is going to take but you know what
is the size of the growth let me give
you an example and I'm going to come
back to the car industry today you have
about 700 cars per 1000 residents in the
United States you have about 500 cars
per one
thousand residents in Europe okay you
have less than 100 cars per 1000
resident in China you have less than 50
cars per 1000 resident in India you have
less than 200 cars per 1000 residents in
Russia you have less than 300 cars per
1000 residents in Brazil imagining that
Brazil India Russia and China are going
to remain at the lower level of
motorization than Europe is ridiculous
and all these countries is going to grow
and they're going to reach at least the
level of Portugal or Spain if not if not
more so when you are in China in the
case of China at 100 less than 100 car
per 1000 inhabitants and Portugal is at
500 you can imagine that Chinese market
is going to continue to grow a lot
particularly when you know that the
government of China is investing
massively in infrastructure which is one
of the limitation for which maybe it's
not going to happen investing massively
in infrastructure investing massively in
education investing massively in
everything which is going to trigger
this will to have autonomous autonomous
transportation so back to your question
I think developing countries are huge
and tremendous opportunity for companies
for young people you know I was two days
ago having a lunch with the Brazilian
entrepreneur and he was telling me you
know if I was 23 years old today
I would go to Myanmar he's Brazil I said
why they say well I see in Myanmar the
way Brazil was 30 years ago
60 million habitants very rich country
economy totally mismanage willingness to
open to open the country and I say you
know I have the impression that I know
how this is going to go and I want to
benefit from it
so what you're going to have a
repetition in a different way of stories
but my point is emerging market are a
huge opportunity as long as you have the
lucidity to analyze each one of them by
itself and see all the metrics which
matter for your industry or your area of
interest but it's not going to be linear
you're not going to
ups and down and stabilization and
consolidation and then access
acceleration without any doubt huge
opportunity over here on our stage left
thank you for presentation my name is
Chris Davis I'm doing a Fulbright
scholarship from London it's probably a
very simple question but in terms of
personality traits or common themes
either in what what you need to be in
your position or similar roles or your
level in terms of common personality
traits to be successful
frankly I don't think I don't think you
have a lot of things in common between
if you take for example the 1,000 are
just company in the world today I don't
think you can say there is something
common to all these people I can't and
you can I mean I can see it personally
because every year I go to Davos which
is the largest concentration of CEO in
the world at a certain place and we meet
a lot of people you know and it's very
interesting because we meet Russian CEOs
and Chinese heroes and Indian CEOs and
Brazilians and Vietnamese and Cambodian
and they come all over the world and you
will say oh oh there must be something
common between all them no no the
approach is completely different I don't
think you can say there is one single
attribute or a little bit of commonality
between between all these all these
people I don't think so
certainly there is all of them want
somehow to contribute
that's for sure a lot of them do not
take no for an answer you know there are
some things like this but I've seen in
terms of personality approach Drive I
don't think there is something there is
something coming okay this will be the
last question there back here back row
again thank you very much for taking the
time to talk to us on your point about
electric cars as you well know building
out a electric charging infrastructure
both has chicken and egg problem someone
has to move first and it's a highly
regulated space
so as we're a group of MBAs what's the
one thing that you would recommend that
we as MBA is focus on if we want to see
that built out I would say today we are
concentrating that been large company
who are investing on electric cars are
concentrating on these areas of the
world where leaders of the countries see
a problem behind too much dependence on
oil and co2 emissions being not
something fabricated artificially but a
real threat ok so whenever you have
these two elements then you are we are
around the table I'm going to give you
an example I sat down with the I'm
Brazilian I sat down with the president
of Brazil we were talking electric cars
immediately I I've seen that she was not
a believer in electric cars I said ok
that's fine no problem we're not going
to concentrate our efforts on Brazil we
are concentrating our efforts on China
we're gonna subject outward in Japan
we're going to concentrate our efforts
in the United States because there are
leaders here who are saying well you
know what too much dependence on oil is
a problem and co2 is not something
fabricated it is something real and if
you don't pay attention to this we're
going to have serious serious problem so
what I would like to tell you is as if
you want to go into this area which is
environmentally friendly transportation
and particularly with the electric cars
first you need to make sure that you're
dealing with people who don't consider
it only as a business but consider it as
a must I mean when you have a problem of
the size of the co2 emission and you
have the solution to this problem
you just cannot ignore it by saying you
know what it's not the time I'm going to
wait until something happens before I
jump in no we have a solution we have
the technology we need to move it in and
we're going to have to find our way to
make it a reality a reality of the
business
from time to time it may take it may
take a lot of efforts may take a lot of
investments your efforts cannot be
rewarded but when it will take off in my
opinion is going to be absolutely
tremendous so my point is just find
allies who are not only see it as an
opportunity but are convinced that it is
the right solution and the technology in
terms of battery motor inverter
everything is moving very fast so I
don't think we're going to add too much
to it everything which is around the
charging system still needs to evolve
lowering the cost of the fast charging
going to systems that allow you to
charge the car in a very convenient way
varies when we started with the fast
charging where the 40 minutes charged
now we are at 20 minutes we have offered
from some suppliers coming to less than
10 minutes where people offering a
system where when you're driving your
car on a highway you can charge through
the through the wheels that means there
is an explosion of ideas coming and I
think this is where innovation is going
to take place but I have no doubt on the
fact that the technology that will
protect the environment and a low at the
same time the explosion of autonomous
transportation particularly through the
development of emerging market is a huge
mind so thank you so much for spending
the time with us today and on behalf of
the entire Stanford Graduate School of
Business mr. Gowen thank you for your
time and thank you for coming
you